dans les cages
18 ans et demi et moi et moi j'ai eu 20
ans on a fait un cambriolage puis été
condamné à une peine de trois ans avec
18 mois de sursis à 18 mois ferme et moi
3 1 avec deux ans ferme et un an de
sursis
majorité pour la justice ajoute beaucoup
même quand on est mineur pouvoir exemple
cette affaire là notre affaire mineure
il aurait pris à tout casser quinze
jours en 20 jours et nous comme on est
majeur charest joue quand même
c'est quand les gens ne font pas
attention à ce qu'ils disent on dit on
est toujours ou et j'arrêterai je
recommencerai plus et pénibles puissent
pas trouver dehors bon massart continue
voile voile pour l'argent mais pour
avoir de l'argent c'est comme si on
disait pourquoi vous travaillez c'est
pareil même chose
si on a de mauvaises fréquentations bon
devient délinquant par la suite
on va dire qu'on est dans un très bon
entourage en invente un montage avis on
peut pas dire c'est un bon entourage
si alicia du vol c'est normal je trouve
qu'à du bois d'amont je trouve ça normal
quand les gens vont chercher du boulot
la paix ni frappe alors dit non déjà ils
ont ils semblent pas rentrer là mois
d'intérim et leur disent ne pas
comprendre
elle contient un ghetto le val fourré un
parce que
si vous aviez quelque chose à dire à vos
copains qui sont toujours au val fourré
qu'est ce que vous leur dernier moi j'ai
rien à dire rien à dire aux copains qui
avaient le choix et je pourrais passer
le bonjour à ma famille de vos copains
non moi je te conseille que les teams -
les grands je m'intéresse pas à ces
galets m'intéresse pas moi je peux
conseiller aux petits et aux plus jeunes
c'est que vaut mieux qu'ils aillent à
l'école qui traverse qui travaillent qui
trouve n'importe quoi mais qu'ils
arrêtent de volée au mieux pour
leur dire la prison c'est pas c'est pas
les vacances comme tout le monde dit
prison c'est dur
vous avez été cambriolé récemment combat
que ça s'est passé ben il soit rentrer
par la porte tout simplement
un capi de biche
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont pris ici leur
caméra bijoux gens tous oui mais je vois
mais ils ont abîmé la maison on est en
haut
j'étais complétement tu l'avais chaumont
livigno heureusement que s'ils ont
l'oreille des français nous amis exprès
mais c'est les clés sur les portes pour
paquin et oui mon esprit c'est fait
machinalement parce que oui je ne
dépends du vécu voilà donc la veille
c'était la voiture le dimanche suivant
c'était l'appartement la voiture de ma
voiture personnelle qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait à l'autoradio nous ça va
et vous savez qui fait ça ou si la
pointe de jeunes les jeunes qui traînent
paris signe sa
dernière ferme hâtif mais
comment comment vous visez ça
psychologiquement
mouhamadou dabo début bon bain au début
gros fan a pas d'autre voie aussi mais
maintenant on vous dit plus rien
des lieux au début j'avais ici vont
gâcher les [ __ ] dehors le bâton
magique fut rien tant qu'il remplit un
rôle important travail et je laisse pas
et s'ils rentrent à nouveau 90
appartements caves alors là il devrait
faire un mois
elles ont la ferme à moulins vous feriez
qui s'appelle qu'il rende ici utilisé
tout jeune culturiste
disons qu'il ira sûrement faire un point
8 ans livide a manqué à deux fois
cambriolé
trois faire le 15 et une fois la voiture
et une fois ici un avortement comme
jeunes curieux vous pensez que un
cambriolage ça peu ce qu'est la mort
c'est quand même pas grave vu la ville
de man comme aller maintenant oui
pourquoi parce que ça il ya beaucoup de
cambriolages au bas du père soit un
moment où il sait ça dure elle ne put an
qu'il était le week-end j'ai par aig
aurait comme effet une semaine de
travail c'est un peu le cas qu'on
cherche
est ce que vous avez peur vous madame
par exemple moi je ne sais pas ce soir
je pense à le dire j'ai sorti une fois
avec ma chaîne ils s'en sont pris la
bande de jeunes à ma chienne je sors
plus soit c'est fini moi quand la nuit
tombe de rachel moi vous avez peur pour
votre votre sécurité ah oui ah oui j'ai
vu d'un autre appartement où on était
avant
un homme de couleur essayer d'enfoncer
la porte j'avais un couteau ces temps là
je pleurais mais je lui ai dit si tu
rentres je tends roche il a peut-être
peur et les partis mais moi je sors plus
le soir d'ailleurs vous verrez pas
français le soir après 10 heures 12
avril mais c'est pas sûr majoritaire ici
maintenant ils étrangers font ce qu'ils
veulent ils ont même essayé plusieurs
fois de mettre le feu à l'immeuble ils
ont pu s après les gens ont très peur
pas mais moi le jour où ça passera la
télévision un tueur encore deux fois
plus peur délinquance juvénile c'est
leur raison sociale ils ont entre 15 et
20 ans ils sont 65 mille en france
majoritairement d'origine étrangère par
milieu une minorité de 16% est
particulièrement active ce sont les
multirécidivistes qui commettent seule
la moitié des délits constatés
cambriolages vols à la tire vols à
l'étalagé
minorité dans la minorité il cristallise
l'angoissé la colère d'une société qui a
trop tardé à s'occuper d'eux
j'avais l'âge de 12 ans pour attaquer
les sites aux
jets à cause des chutes des figures
ouais j'ai fait du chuq pourquoi vous
avec un copain à lui partie de l'école
ne voulait pas aller à l'école il
appartient fut et c'est comme ça que
j'ai arrêté l'école ça se passait mal à
l'épaule ouais et du jour ça se passait
mal du jour ça se passait bien
et après le regret quand quelqu'un te
qui est quoi la 12 ans donc non ça s'est
passé devant toni n'a fait des conneries
on s'est fait place d'un centre à
commencer
par les tablettes de chocolat
ainsi de suite tablette de chocolat tous
les premiers ou banane et magasins
et puis après alors que quelques voilà
qu'est-ce que quel type de conneries
après je vais vous tuer
paul topical cambalache etc
es-tu
nature récemment que j'étais inquiète en
prison ouais j'aime sortir
tu fais combien 13 jours très durs
c'était pour faire
pourquoi
comment ça se passe un cambriolage que
[Musique]
tu me racontes et à la passage envoyait
la balle comme voilà je vais d'abord
on se renseigne quoi on se renseigne dit
sérieusement et bien où on veut comme
relais
et on le fait quand ils sont pas là
quand les jeunes il part au travail ou
en vacances
et lang 2 qui qui font le guet pendant
que les autres vont travailler
et retravailler
cambrai l'école
mais parler d'une minuterie
ouest à 12 ans
on était trois avec deux de mes
collègues on a été en affaires on a fait
une bijouterie
on prend ça s'est passé d'abord on a été
au bon marché moi je suis maintenant on
a fait une caisse ensuite on a pris le
train on a été faire dans une ville un
peu plus loin on est entré dans un
magasin de jouets voilà je sais du fou
pistolet en est révéré plus très juste à
côté on le dépiste lambeaux ci avec des
pistolets non c'était les puces et les
pétards quoi
on l'a fait et la bijouterie qui sont en
effet on a pris et sacoches où il y
avait de l'argent vous êtes avec vos
buts on a la mer vous avez crié ou les
mains ou way you lie à la
tâche accroché on se sauver
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé avant
ryan bourque a voulu qu a voulu
l'attraper mais il avait entendu qu'on
parle et qu'on cherchait la gare il a
discuté on s'entend mais non on a couru
d'abord après on s'est arrêté pour
savoir où elle était la garde et un
bonhomme qui nous a suivis et il est
entendu là où que cherche la garde cela
vous disiez tout fort qu'on soit vrai il
a voulu nous attrapons on s'est sauvés
on s'est dit qu'on sépare les deux sont
partis ensemble moi je suis parti de mon
côté et après j'étais à la guerre après
j'ai vu des flics et il était dharejo il
s'était fait attraper elles soient
récents venus à malte ont cherché
mais pour toi c'est mal de volume c'est
bien
au fond c'est mal
parce qu on m a pas qu'on nous vole je
sais
c'est pas un métier
et unie au fond c'est mal ça veut dire
que moralement tu penses que c'est
condamnable comment ça c'est si tu dis
c'est mal ce qu'il faut pas le faire
ouais il faut pas le faire
mais il n'a qu ils feront quoi ça n'est
jamais arrivé d'avoir un problème au
cambodge si un jour une fois la étiez en
a sonné persona ouverture derrière on a
fracturé la vitre
le copain avec sa main il a ouvert la
poignée il a poussé les deux fenêtres
personne n'a fait la courte échelle
juste - jeu pour un trait y avait un
monsieur qui était cachée avec une
goutte et g j'ai sauté en arrière on
s'est sauvés mais tu as eu peur ah oui
je comprends j'ai eu peur est-ce que ça
dès ce que ça t'a fait peur pour re pour
plus tard parce que tu t'es dit je
pourrais tomber sur nasa
je repasse qu ils ont rigolé après caen
est revenu
c'est sa copine je n'aime pas la police
qui viennent frapper tout le temps total
à côte je n'aime pas le betis qui fut
mon fils mais ils ne coûtent pas
tout le temps je te parle je te parie
arrête ça et il utilise avec les u18
écoutent pas s'est pas qu'il ya toute
façon les corail travail une fois une
semaine en une semaine jour
j'arrive pas à garder les enfants et les
parents fatigués
on a passé l'âge entre les joueurs et à
sa mère il donne tous les jours à fra et
team suivante fera et il n'arrive pas de
pour les enfants pour les jaunes à 10
francs pour les cigarettes est différent
le flip pierres et des fois il faut
encore l'argent pour café pur cinéma
mois gagnent quatre cent mille et ma
famille donc hoymille sa vie mille
peuple pour amoindrir pour acheter leur
billet pour les petits-enfants encore on
frappe à jour sacré
pour compter 60 milles par mois
seulement pour les garçons et l'autre
côté à l'autre et encore le petit
on a travaillé en france les parents et
les enfants et à l'école de france et
son l'habitude de la france et elle n'a
pas l'habitude du maroc
commencent à commencer pour toi
faire des bêtises
des fois on n'avait pas en cours puis on
avait faim tout ça va tu défends d'aller
prendre des affaires à manger des trucs
à manger tout ça
mais après ça a été tu n'avais pas
d'argent commence à prendre des affaires
tout ça
et après c'est fini c'est parce que tu
n'as pas d'argent ouais c'est ça tu vas
bientôt avoir 18 ans bon ça risque
d'être plus dur si tu te fais attraper
est ce que tu penses à ça ah ouais j'y
pense mais toute façon ça y est c'est
d'arrêter
mais tu dis s'est arrêtée mais quand on
sait quand on s'est revu la première
fois il ya deux mois tu nous avais dit
il m'avait dit déjà s'est arrêtée c'est
fini et puis cet été bon fait
entre-temps tués justement c'est à ce
moment là que tu as fait tes été très
urgent pour moi alors c'était s'était
arrêtée mais s'était pas arrêtée mais je
sais pas comment c'est passé s'est passé
trop vite
mettez ensemble puis il yal un caddie
pont vont enfin un appartement on n'a
pas d'argent rien puis on ait un sas
entre des qua non
non ne pouvais pas dire non puis on
accepte ou pas tirer copains qui propose
d'aller faire un appartement on peut pas
dire non ça dépend si on a de l'argent
busain de cambrioler mais si on n'a rien
et tout pour nos besoins d'argent
acquise yvan des fois
et tu parle d'argent
comment ça se passe pour toi l'orge est
hanté par abandonne
menton mais c'est pas assez
et donc combien 50 francs 50 heures par
semaine et ça suffit pas
et tu crois que tu es parents pour et en
donner plus
ben non je crois pas non chaque et que
mon père qui travaille puis qu'un pas
beaucoup
ma mère non plus à travaille pas puis à
8 enfants déjà huit enfants
cette roue
de toute façon je n'ai pas demandé de
l'argent n'est pas
pourquoi
pourquoi je sais pas déjà ils ont pas
besoin d'un ils n'ont pas beaucoup
d'argent puis
je trouve ça va pas bientôt tu trouves
que je savais très bien demander de
l'argent mais est ce que par rapport à
tes parents est ce que c'est bien de
voler alors ah non non non les
impressions
t'as pas peur de se faire arrêter de
arrêté par la police à la prison ainsi
j'ai peur c'est le bisc
nos risques c'est-à-dire
à combrée faut bien à un risque on sait
très bien que les flics qui seront
derrière nous quand tu vois ton avenir
toi voilà chambon avenir que
je travaillerai que j'aurai une femme
des enfants tous
c'est ça que j'aimerais devenir voilà
c'est ça du une amie actuellement
tu fret en cascade
ouais ouais ouais
un an en option avec elle
et c'est important pour toi cette
formation actuelle
ouais c'est quoi un peu importants
est ce que par exemple dans l'impression
que ça te
d'être avec quelqu'un depuis un an ça
t'incite à ne plus faire de bêtises
ouais ouais
ouais parce que quand elle est partie en
vacances des cas est parti puis c'est
pour ça que je suis tombé
là suffit que deux mois qu à part
pendant deux mois puis
j cambrioler quant à elle là bas je fais
rien et pourquoi quand tu peux expliquer
ça
bah je suis souvent avec elle puis je
suis pas tellement avec les autres mais
quand tu avec elle ça monte psg avec les
autres ça m'empêche de
revenus
qui vient
tu viens discuter de thaler l'ust
rappelle que moi quitte à son procès
il faudrait qu'on dise plus de voir ce
qu'il faut faire tu viens
tu t'es encore paraît sereine que non et
tu as quitté l'école en juin et n'a pas
été encore presque à vos petits quand
même un peu gonflé en vacances en
vacances et les vacances et quoiqu'elle
va-t-on payer des vacances quand tu vas
te retrouver devant le tribunal si tu te
passe au tribunal et que tu t'amènes que
t'es pas inscrit dans une agence que tes
passions d'avoir du boulot que tu
t'amènes et encore sans rien dire sans
savoir quoi dire à la juge ça va pas
être terrible
que je vois que
tu es blessé
tu rapportes aurait pu inscrire avant si
on n'est pas là pour vous botter les
fesses pour vous emmener
la flemme c'est beau hein c'est si dur
que ça n'allait pas tout ça oui plein
coeur prémices de monde n'oublie pas
tous tes papiers parce que j'étais
nerveux avec toi et je suis arrivé
devant les buts mais aucun papier sur
toi
on vient pour m'inscrire à l'anpe parce
qu'il n'a jamais été inscrit bien donc
voulait rentrer dans la vie active à
l'heure actuelle il n'ya moi je dois
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
n'ayant pas de diplôme
il se peut peut-être que vous les
difficultés
qu est ce que vous souhaiteriez dans ce
canal
[Musique]
non monsieur
vous bien jean lui que tu passes au
tribunal de versailles est-ce que c'est
inquiète
voilà pour
mes tu risques turris quelque chose
de dommages et intérêts j'ai tout
c'était pour quelle affaire c'est pour
un cambriolage
et qui était encore vierge pour way
s'est passé et en gt les mineurs
qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que ça peut
donner comme jugement une affaire comme
ça
du sort c'est peut-être ce qui à l'affût
il s'agite et incarcéré depuis
douze jours je crois
alors
on peut avoir que du sursis maintenant
équipements un peu comment ça passe une
journée ici ou à ce jour pareil on se
réveille on se retrouve dans un antre et
là vers midi une heure points reste un
super l'entrée avec la musique tout est
prêt on vient au local sinon le soir
c'est pareil de l'entrée l'entrée à
nouveau certaines des histoires qui sont
passés à dézoner ou des fois qu'on suit
attrapé ensemble raconte qu'on était
commissariat une otite et sa lotus et ça
rigole
et du temps du pain peut
s'y met il n'y a rien d'autre à faire
qu'est ce que tu aimerais faire d'autre
que ça que je reste ici trois journées
oui
mais est-ce que tu es prêt à accepter
n'importe quel travail pour avoir
d'argent bon bien sûr
tu pourras la cuisine par exemple ouais
je crois la musique nous manque c'est à
la fin tu m'enrichis des sous c'est ça
le reste comment tu aimerais vie au plus
tard
normalement
un boulot un petit appartement
femme tranquille
tu peux expliquer pourquoi apportant au
rôle pourquoi tu voles toi
joël pour eux
pour avoir des sous
pour rendre au musée bien comme je
voudrais
comment s'amuser à faire des choses
aller à paris au musée du cinéma quand
je lui à la patinoire et puis
pour bien m'amuser quoi
ou pour m'acheter des trucs montferrand
propre pays
si tu avais d'argent ça ça veut dire que
tu ne voudrais pas
defour et combien d'argent par semaine
pour
pour tes besoins
forcement
400 à 500 francs si tous
arrêtez
vous faites pas ça
[Applaudissements]
des fois on est dans les escaliers bon
fanboy des gens et 18 par des escaliers
mon mari dans la journée ce soir va
travailler bien on défend et le soir
bombe a fait pas le bruit les petits
demain ils vont à l'école il leur parle
comme ça mais en fin de compte si s'y
prête gentiment voir ils arrêteront mais
pourront ils sont dans les escaliers ils
sont toujours en train de fumer avant de
rigoler comme ça mais sont assez tard
dans les marches rct délinquants parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de travail que tu déjà
arrivé de faire des choses pas à pas
tout à fait autorisé mois ce qui
m'arrivait le volet c'était plutôt des
affaires mara j'ai pas d'argent puis
j'ai été tenté par une robe ou pas par
un pantalon par un t-shirt mais bon
comme je pouvais pas la foire parce que
j'ai pas d'argent
j'ai pris et puis j'ai réussi ma
sinon s'il fallait l'acheter bas
je crois pas que j'aurais eu mais ce
sont des affaires ont grand besoin non
j'ai pas besoin enfin qui me plaisait
quoi j'aurais bien voulu avoir chez moi
je sais comme je n'avais pas d'argent je
pouvais pas me permettre d acheter
j'ai essayé
tu dis jamais fait parents n'ont jamais
étudiants n'avaient pas vraiment besoin
mais elle me plaisait mais en même temps
tu sais que c'est interdit oui c'est
interdit et donc simplement parce que ça
te plaisais tu as pris le risque j'ai
pris le risque
et tu te dis pas que c'était quand même
très dangereux très risqué hausse est
moins risqué que d'aller cambrioler
d'attaquer une petite vieille ou quelque
chose comme ça
comment comment ça se passe chez toi
dans ta famille
mais chez moi on est neuf il ya la
plupart ils font à l'école
sinon j'ai que la grande soeur qui
travaille ça qu'à 30 ans et puis mon
père ils sont deux à travailler chez moi
un peu tard jeu comprendra un
appartement pour moi
ensuite nous marier et travailler puis
après avoir des enfants
et dix mois sur les enfants si si comme
quand ils auront 15 ans 16 ans s'ils se
mettent à faire des bêtises comme comme
on est copains ont font un petit peu
comment tu vas lire
moi j'aimerais pas qu'il fasse ça pour
moi vous je préférais pas mes enfants de
sortir ou bien d'être libre mais pour
moi l'école sera sacré moi je veux que
mes enfants plus tard ils apprennent
ils auront droit de sortir comme ils
voudront moi je vais priverait de rien
mais ce que je veux c'est qu'ils vont à
l'école j'ai pas qu'il soit comme moi à
16 ans 17 ans sans travail sans rien
reste à la maison bien aller dans les
quartiers traîner
moi je préfère les voir avec un quelque
chose en main comme ça même plus tard
ben s'ils doivent pas à partir quitter
la maison mais elles auront un travail
ça sera plus facile à trouver
pour toi l'école ça s'est pas très bien
passé mais j'ai pas voulu apprendre mes
parents une force et enfin moi j'allais
à l'école et puis après j'ai connu des
filles enfin j'allais faire comme elle
est allée voir des copains dans un local
j'en avais qu'elle disait bon on va pas
en cours c'est pas intéressant j allais
pas me croire mais par un croyais que j
allais et jusqu'au jour où ma mère elle
a été rappelée à l'école et puis ils ont
dit non peut plus garder votre fille
16 ans que ce qu'il aurait fallu te dire
mon couturier l'école
je sais pas à mon avis c'était à moi de
réfléchir
maintenant c'est trop tard
dis moi tu es e
tu es amoureuse d'un garçon de la bande
ouais
ça fait un an et demi que faire avec
et c'est avec lui que tu vois ton avenir
bat normalement pour moi ouais c'est pas
pour mon entourage me par an pour mes
frères et soeurs pour mes frères et
soeurs sont faux ils s'en fichent parce
qu'ils sont encore jeunes et peu
éprouvée par an plus tôt puis pour les
entourages
parce que pour eux ce moment avec un
français c'est pas
très bien pourquoi leurs coutumes ses
deux mariés se marier jeune se maria
avec eux un garçon de leur nationalité
enfin cas du travail qui est un beau
métier 15
mai pour moi
pour toit celui pour moi c'est nuire ou
pour leur faire comprendre cette chose
- château donc pas la selve arrive de
faire de bêtises acquis à jean-luc
au début avant que je sorte avec enfin
vers les débuts je connaissais pas bien
j'étais pas souvent avec lui ça lui est
arrivé de faire des bêtises maintenant
que j'ai avec lui je lui dit pas faire
des fins d'éviter pour sa soeur
varioptic monoï était majeure c'était
plus comme avant quand il était mineur
bon ça allait mais je dis ma lentille
majeur et puis
vint à l'armée alors me qui se tiennent
tranquilles mais tu as l'impression que
tu écoutes quand tu lis ça
bat plutôt qu'ils me respectent pas ce
que
regarde on écoute une fille c'est rare
mais ils me respectent plus tôt
et respecte tout ça veut dire ma faim
moi comme dit de faire quelque chose je
le fais bompas respect quand même du bon
je crois que tu fasses ça je le fais pas
bon bah moi temps en temps quand on a
envie de faire quelque chose de ma
jument ce pas la peine de le faire ça
sert à rien et tout bon magnifique de
pas le faire enfin il ne fait pas quoi
et si un jour il faisait une grosse
bêtise alors que tu lui a dit de ne pas
la faire quand tu réagirais
mais après je dirais d'abord cité c'est
bien fait pour lui s'il se fait attraper
voilà c'est un bienfait premier puis
je crois que je laisserais tomber parce
que j'ai prévenu déjà plus et je lui ai
dit plusieurs fois d'arrêter alors s'ils
n'écoutent pas bah
je peux rien faire d'autre j'ai
l'impression des coûtants que les filles
vous réfléchissez beaucoup plus à ces
problèmes d'avenir d'argent ce que tu as
l'impression que ils réfléchissent à
leur avenir moi quelques-uns mais les
autres je crois qu'il faudra encore
quelques années pour qu'il s'en sorte
parce que pour eux bar pense pas leur
avenir pense pas à fonder une maison
travail et avoir leur permis
11 pas ça qu'est ce que tu aimerais
faire communiquer moment ce qui m'a
toujours plu comme métier c'est garder
les enfants enfin comme père et culte
rice ou animatrice ou quelque chose
comme ça mais faut avoir le bac on va
avoir plus ou moins cher c'est trop tard
maintenant
et du coup quand il va falloir que tu tu
cherche du travail dans lequel le
secteur tu cherches
une des trois plus réductrice
basher un truc simple sonnerait
prospectus ou bien avant 2 ou je peux
pas faire du ménage quelque part chez
des gens garder les enfants
mais je crois que plus tard si je devrai
travailler sera plutôt dans une usine
bien comme vendeuse
je sens plus française qu'algérienne
de caractère et tout y
est dans ta famille on
ne triche pas on n'obligera pas les
vivres là bas non non non ne seront pas
si tu vas faire ta vie ici quoi moi je
vais faire ma vie ici ça me plairait pas
de la faire là bas
moi tu es ce que tu es heureux ici
heureuse
voilà ça va
tu as l'air d'hésiter
moi si j'avais du travail si
si j'avais mon appartement si j'avais
tout ce que je désire d'accord
chaleureuse mais
pour l'instant ça va un peu mais on
verra plus tard tu viens tout juste de
sortir de prison la tunisie était
pourquoi
qu'on voit là je crois pas trop grave tu
reste combien je compte un maximum 6 -
je resté combien de temps un mois
toujours
aller en prison aurait coché ce que tu
as fait souvent
qu'est-ce que fini
genre si on pouvait faire marche arrière
je ferai autre chose nous sera pas là
mais c'est le destin tient ce n'est pas
de casser le moral pas trop réfléchi
reporter
quand tu vas en prison dont tu renvoies
un peu comme un gps que tu te dis je
recommencerai plus
je te pose la question parce qu'on sait
que quand on s'était vus de la première
fois il ya deux mois tu m'avais dit pas
non maintenant c'est fini je ferai plus
le cambriolage j'ai j'ai passé 18 ans
donc je risque d'être qu'on avait
beaucoup plus dur moi je ferai plus de
fabricants réglages et puis deux mois
après tu te retrouves
mais voilà je l'âge et je peux vous le
faire
c'est comme ça le soit rediscuté tard le
conseil d'état un copain que moi je dis
non c'est pas un peu je sais qu il
devient l'assistant du régime mais du
même âge en trois sets au deuxième étage
sur le pacha stobart son côté jan filc
auch tarbes axes comme si je faisais
ok quoi
vous savez quand même ce que tu prenais
moi j'ai récemment
je savais je pensais pas que
tu arrêtes ton des tonnes jour pour ça
déjà et je pensais pas qu elle soit
rattrapé les
[Musique]
dix mois en prison colette vais te voir
qu'est ce que ça représente pour toi
connais tu
sais
tu aurais une deuxième mère fois c'est
que c'est tout de moi
je suis vraiment dans mes problèmes
c'est la commune de la relation est
quand même venu le voir en prison par
les coaches parle avec vous je sais pas
peut aller d'un commissariat puissant
j'ai parlé avec les les inspecteurs
tu penses qu'elle t'aide justement
pourtant amis c'est beaucoup
tu dis que c'est un peu une deuxième
mère pour toi mais chez toi dans ta
famille croit qu est ce que ça se passe
avec tes parents mais
je passe bien
ton père comment il est avec toi mais
bien si je suis bien ici si tu peux bien
mais et fabien aussi c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qui fait si je vais travailler
et ça se passe comment
si je pense à tous les coups il se
comprendre moi je c'est pas est-ce que
ça t'empêche de recommencer non c'est
pas ça qui est compétent pour moi c'est
ça ça te fait c'est de la peur vertes
auprès par votre pas voir ton père cours
mais se trouve page pas c'est pas cool
ça ferait s'est produit au moins vous
les
faire marcher pour quelqu'un comme ça
mais vrai s'y prendre je prends moi nous
tombons pour le tfc s'est préparé la
cinétique après celle reçue proches par
la parole et c'est de parler discuter si
mieux
le grès des toits discute avec son père
son père décide de prendre la parole et
infléchir le jura bernois est par
exemple on perd c'est moi condra tout
c'est comme ça ça lui devoir lui donner
des conseils beaucoup de conseils de bon
sa du pouvoir a choisi étudie colette
elle avec la tempe armés j'attends quand
même pas empêché sur des bêtises
on va pour l'été
peut-être deux mois et colette à vouloir
m'en sortir mais ses copains qui sont
qu'il faudrait qu'il soit avec nous
aussi si son bagout c'est moi suce pas
toujours la connaître elle est la
chanson je suis pas toujours la keith
newton ce qu'avec les autres toujours
avec eux c'est là qu'ils savent où je
serai toujours à connaître - colette à
mon endroit longera droit mais avec
cette marche mais c'est normal
c'est pour ça que je dis vous partir des
livres
bon tu vois ton avenir
c'était
je le vois bien mais je ne le vois pas
partir quoi je vois pas comment je vais
réussir à me sortir au sénat je vois
bien je vois bien finir c'est quoi la
baie la famille tranquille a fortement
l'emploi son poulain
[Musique]
et vous savez qui fait ça vous l'apport
de jeunes les jeunes qui traînent paris
signe sa
deuxième femme hâtif mais
disons qu'on a des doutes et s'il rentre
un nouveau drop appartement que nous
avons alors là il devrait faire un mois
vous feriez quoi oui moi sociale qui
s'appelle qu'ils rentrent ici et qu'il y
va c'est toujours le tube ajouté disons
qu'il sera sûrement faire un pouce et 8
ans la vita morte qui avait eu deux fois
cambriolé
thurien
[Musique]
attention vous patrick jagaille tirer
dans les pattes gavage et jazz qui est
un mec comme déchire iso vaut d'ailleurs
dû alors
est ce qu'on en pense et
de se parler europe 1
qu'est-ce que vous fassiez en général de
des réactions des gens à votre égard
quand c'est pas un point de vue
enfin à mentir pour dire qu'elle avait
des jeunes qui sortaient le couteau et
commencé que je marque c'est une eau qui
l'encombré chez elle
mais d'autre part
il dira enfin est ce qu'on pense aux
gens qu'on va voler le ballon
on perd constamment ce pas
ça te t'as pas de réaction à cet été -
ja
peut-être qu'ils sont cons panel temps
brioni
l'assurance pour lui dire qu'elle 2
millions et 10 5 millions et
[Musique]
je crois qu'on peut être content à 15
comme
si l'on revient chez eux et qu'ils
disent qu'ils avaient magnétophone et
chaîne stéréo et tout doit alors
donc vous pensez jamais oh vous pensez
maintenant victime aux gens qui sont qui
sont cambriolés aussi un jeune il a
besoin d'argent puis
il va cambriolé pense moi tu che qui va
le faire ou pourquoi il fait ça au
curage et après mes
pauses d'abord havre alors
tenter par l'argent s'en faut que ceux
qui vont faire ça
est ce que ça vous embête par rapport à
des gens comme ce qu'on vient de voir
mais des gens 22 généralement est ce que
ça vous embête avoir une image de marque
une étiquette comme ça de délinquants
économiques et des délinquants
nous
non non
je sais que d'un cran
battus quand même quelqu'un qui
tient fait la prison par exemple
[Musique]
des marques et des hommes politiques qui
font de la prise c'est de verser 56
ouais
donc vous refuser l'étiquette désaccord
tout le monde met ce qu'ils veulent sur
l'étiquette
moi je sais pas ce que ça veut dire de
l'unc en vrai au nom d'un autre mur
marty dans les escaliers on discute on
s'amuse t dehors jusqu'à huit heures et
demie du soir on avait délinquants mais
ça prend des coups de la musique est un
délinquant
du marchand ben thabet d'accord c'est
vrai
non mais sérieux il ya quand même des
raisons qu'on fait venir vous avez vous
avez tous plus ou moins eu affaire à la
police avec la justice avec la prison
donc mêlant tous les jeunes c'est bien
après tout chanson alors y'a pas de
problème là-dessus tous les jeunes
nettoient robert tu refuses tu refuse
l'étiquette
star en sus la porte voix synthétique
est revenu je la refuse
pas de quitter vers la fin de
chaque citoyen comme tous les autres
citoyens
il ya plus de vingt ans on a fait venir
les parents pour travailler dans les
usines sans se donner les moyens d'une
véritable intégration aujourd'hui il
faut faire face même si le prix à payer
est beaucoup plus élevé
souvent critiqué pour son apparent
d'indulgence colette l'éducatrice tente
l'impossible pour limiter les dégâts en
attendant que l'intégration dans la vie
les adultes se fasse peu à peu
alors il pose quand même un problème ces
jeunes à qui bon leur délinquance s'est
quand même dit on répétitives c'est à
dire que ils vont pas s'arrêter après
quand ils font une première betty ils
vont pas s'arrêter tout de suite il ya
quand même une comme ça une répétition
de
des vols qui commettent et ça les gens
ne supportent de moins en moins alors
quel est votre point de vue là dessus
qu'est ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut
supporter jusqu'où on peut supporter
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il faut qu à
l'attitude faut-il avoir par rapport à
ça fait chic parisien quand ils se font
voler un autoradio ils ont bien content
moi même si je me serais iv voler une
mère je serais vraiment pas content mais
il faut le voir comme ça tout le temps
dans le quartier ils veulent pas
toujours les appartements comme on a
tendance à le dire parce que ça c'est
trop facile aussi on a été cambriolée
c'est les jeunes du quartier sont des
gosses quand on sait les et mes
conseillers s'en occuper bon ils se
tiennent tranquilles mais si les gens
quand des jeunes sont sur un escalier
qui commence à les bousculer ou leur
dire de sortir dans un old house tout ça
parce qu'ils jouent aux cartes soient we
dance est bien aussi si on leur dit
poliment dont ça craque est-ce que
parfois vous ne craignez pas que pour
eux ce sera trop tard non
non c'est pas trop tôt
ils s'en sortiront moi j'en ai vu des
plus vieux qu'eux qui s'en sont bien
sorties qui ont famille enfants et qui
travaillent vous croyez qu'ils sont
encore qu'une sont encore accessibles
vous allez me dire ils sont récupérables
ou pas allez-y franchement c'est ça nous
avait envie de dire oui si on sauve
qu'on peut faire quelque chose pour eux
il suffit qu'on est un peu moins de
qu'on puisse faire des choses pour eux
c'est à dire du travail les aider leur
faire des distractions
pour eux c'est à dire que quand ils vont
au cinéma qui sont vingt fois que ça ou
24 francs il faut déjà chercher les 4
francs pour mon voulez vous qu'ils
n'arrivent pas défaut à voler est ce que
vous vous remplacez la famille non pas
du tout je pense pas que j'en ai même
pas la mer à nos normes dont le mât de
la non non non non non mais quand il ya
un passé une glace je regarde je suis
persuadé que leur mère les engueuler pas
comme moi des fois je les engueule parce
que bon chez eux tout est rose ils
mangent ils boivent ils s assiette le
vert et tous ici une cuisine s'ils
boivent du thé ou du café son intérêt ne
l'avait leur verre parce que les
animateurs qui se travaille avec nous
parce qu'on a des animateurs de jeunes
sspa sont pas là pour leurs faits
d'armes vers parce que les filles jouent
un rôle important dans leur valant
réinsertion future oui
oui parce que j'ai pas beaucoup de
filles qui sortent a vécu et aussitôt
qu'ils en ont une ils ont envie de la
garder
et la garder ça veut dire aussi
se stabiliser plus faire de conneries
parce que c'est les parents de la fille
qu'ils empêchent de sortir après qu'ils
disent tu vas pas sortir avec ça c'est
moins que rien ça sent même dans nos
gars là il y en a deux qui fréquentent
un petit peu
la mère frissonne tranquille en plus si
un jour il va en taule c'est attention
il est en prison donc savoir
même si la mère elle ne pense pas dire à
sa fille pour +10 orthez qui essayait
d'empêcher mettre des bâtons dans les
roues
il n'y a pas des jours où colas tout
vous vous êtes un peu quand même
découragé déçu par par ce travail qui
est un travail et apparemment de longue
haleine bien tarif quand il ya un garçon
qui se suicident que vous apprenez qui
vient de 6,8 idée parce qu'on n'a pas su
y trouver du boulot et c'est pas qu'on a
pas su mais c'est qu'il n'y avait
absolument rien alors là on est
découragés ont dit qu'is à quoi ça sert
qu'on allait voir en taule à quoi ça
sert qu'on a il en haleine que si
derrière il nous arrive un coup comme ça
mais c'est rare qu'on se décourage pas
ce qu'ils sont gentils lula moi je pense
qu'ils vont se stabiliser
il y en a là dans la bande de jeunes que
vous avez vu qu'ils de même bon ont
envie de s'en sortir ils le disent on
voudrait un jour se marier avoir des
enfants vivent comme nous l'exemple
c'est vif comme nous peut-être qu'on
vient vous comme nous on est un petit
exemple des fois ça nous fait rire parce
que
on travaille on est un couple qui
travaillons tous les deux donc mais pour
e.on et la famille la famille qui
s'occupe de gosses qui s'est lui donner
de l'argent de poche qui passe ses
week-ends avec pascal la moitié du temps
quand on les écoute il aimerait bien
aussi avoir une famille qui les sortent
avec qui faire des tas de trucs avec
hull on me dit ça mais aussi il explique
que quand ils sont avec les copains il y
en a un qui propose quelque chose et
puis tout le monde personne ne résiste à
tout le monde y va parce que vous pensez
que le désir de s'en sortir de deux de
créer une famille comme la vôtre est
suffisamment fort pour pour aller à
l'encontre du aussi du désir qui est
plus facile à vendre et d'aller voler
oui mais ça ils prennent conscience
quand ils ont un certain âge de fonder
un foyer travailler les mêmes là il y en
a qui convient très bon signe deux mêmes
y en a qui viennent et qui nous disent
on venait même qu' il y en a qu il faut
pousser quand même vous avez dû voir il
y en a que je pousse au qui viennent un
peu mais de même après quand ils sont
dans l'agrainage de laine que travailler
la mairie ce que le maire a fait
l'engrenage de sa fait qu'il y en a un
qui m'a dit l'autre jour colette je veux
passer les concours de la sncf et je
passe les concours de ptt donc c'est
l'engrenage qui fait qu'ils ont envie un
jour de s'en sortir alors du coup votre
rôle c'est de faire que ce passage
se passe le mieux possible
ici font comme tout le monde
ça c'est pas
y en a d'autres il ya eu des garçons
comme eux puis qui à présent une petite
paye et qui élève des gosses aussi un
puits où ils sont rangés
ça durera pas toujours mais il craint
notamment tu aura quand même pas des
délinquants toute notre vie ça j'espère
un jour au chômage noces
[Musique]